le monde du silence jusque dans une
piscine un calme apparent qui demande un
peu de travail de concentration
rendu célèbre en 1988 avec le film de
luc besson
l'apnée est pratiqué par le club de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'apnée c'est prendre conscience qu'on
est que l'être humain est capable de
faire des choses que le mental pense
qu'il peut pas faire on apprend une
respiration spéciale pour les apnéistes
que de pratiquer tous les apnéistes et
on apprend surtout à se détendre
le maître mot pour le téléthon les
apnéistes se lanceront un challenge
réaliser un maximum de longueur de 25 m
qu'ont en six heures à la piscine
salvador allende des clayes-sous-bois
pour l'apnée c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que les gens qui vont
participer doivent avoir un minimum de
niveau rap n'est qu'un on peut pas se
permettre pour des raisons de sécurité
de faire venir n'importe quelle personne
yara également
de la plongée donc il va y avoir des
baptêmes organisé également de la nage
l'âge classique en surface donc le défi
est lancé pour le samedi 7 décembre dès
14 heures les dons seront reversés à
l'afm téléthon